ああああああ
改めましてや師まいこと申します
お茶に関する仕事をしているので茶人とをご紹介していただくこともあります
巨人は英語で t マスターといいますがマスターという言葉がしっくりこないので
ps とと名乗っています
実家が大々作動をしていたわけではなく親は書道の方をしています
[音楽]
私が書道ではなく作動しているのは理由は一つで食べることのほうが好きだったから
です
お茶の仕事といえばメジャーなのは茶道教室の先生ですが私は先生ではなく今は生徒で
もありません
仕事でもプライベートでも
茶道教室ではない場所でお茶をたてて振る舞ったりお茶の写真を撮ったりしていますが
その活動の目的はこれもーちゃだということです
急にこれも茶だって言われてもどういう意味かよくわからないですよね
茶道を習っていない人やお茶にあんまり詳しくなさそうな人が自己流でお茶をたてて
いるといわれるのがこれはお茶じゃないという言葉ですそれを踏まえてこれもちゃだと
言っているのが私の活動です
今作動している人の大半が茶道教室に通っているため教室に通わずに作動している人は
少数です
教室に通わずにお茶を仕事にしている人はもっと少数です
マイノリティーと言っていいでしょう
当たり前から外れてしまった人がマイノリティになるのは茶道の世界に限った話では
ありません
例えば5結構されているんですかとか大学はどちらですかと何気なくて聞いたり聞かれ
たりします
しかし日本人の生涯未婚率は年々上がっていますし
大学進学率も55%前後です
2人に1人は大学に入っていません
って人が常識だと考えていることを前提に話を進めるとその常識から外れた人は嫌な
思いをする可能性もあります
これもーちゃだということは茶道の世界でマイノリティな私が生き延びるためのスキル
でもありました
常識を縦に否定されたとしてもこれも何何だということで自分の意見を表明することが
できます
しかしもっと大事なことはこれも何何だということで
自分の意見を主張しながらも誰かを否定せずに済むということです
人を否定しないよう意識するだけで自分の意見が通りやすくなったり誰かに面白がって
もらえたりします
このトークを聞く聴くことでよしあなたが何か排他的な発言をしこれはしてしまってい
たとしてもこれからはもっとマイルドに言い換えられるかもしれません
もちろん私もこのスキルを完璧にマスターしているわけではないのでもし途中で排他的
な発言をしてしまっていたとしてもこのトークを聞いた人だけの秘密にしておいて
ください
このこれもーちゃだというアイディアに至ったのはソドーという少し変わった世界の
影響があります
まず茶道といえば決まりごとが多い世界だというイメージがあるのではないでしょうか
実際その通りなのですが大きく分けて2種類の決まり事があると思っています
一つ目はスポーツやゲームのルールとみています
茶道でもお茶室の中では特別なルールに従って動く必要があります
というのも現代の作動は参加者全員がその特別なルールに従うことによって生まれる
あのトクトクな世界観を味わう遊びでもあるからです
二つ目のルールは
茶道教室に通い続けるためのルールです波面このルールは教室によって大きく異なり
ます
例えばお中元やお歳暮といった季節の愛で季節の挨拶を例に挙げてみます
[音楽]
お世話になった人や先生にビールやゼリーを送るしきたりというのは伝統的な習い事の
世界にはまだ根強くあります
それ自体は全然構いません
ただ面白かったのは私がいた教室では食べ物ではなく現金で収めるように指定されてい
たことです
そしてそのお中元やお歳暮の金額は送り先である先生本人が定めていました
もちろんこういうルールがある教室ばかりではないのでこれから教室に通われる方も
そんなに心配しないでください
これらはあくまで私がいた教室の話です
変わってるなぁと内心思っていましたが教室に通わずに佐渡を続けられる方法が有る
なんて思ってもいませんでした
他の生徒さんもきちんとお金をされていらっしゃいますし
他の教室に移ってもまた同じルールがあるかもしれないですし
しかもそれは映ってみないとわからないことですし
当時は思っていたんです
しかしどうしても
先生の言うことが絶対的な唯一の正解であり
従わないという選択肢がないその教室に馴染めませんでした
結局辞めてしまい私は一人になりました
そこからは主に茶道教室に通っている方
動く一部から
これはお茶じゃないと言われるようになります
もちろん趣味でお茶をたてているだけなら何も言われないことが多いのですが
お茶会を開いたりして人前に出てくるようになると何か言われることもあります
というののお茶会は佐渡の基本をしっかり学んだ人がするべき事だと思われているかと
思われているからです
つのような教室に通ってもいない人がお茶会をしてしかもその内容が彼等や彼女等が
考える
茶道と全然異なっていれば確かにこれはお茶じゃないと言いたくもなるでしょう
[音楽]
このこれもお茶じゃないという言葉には2つの意味があると思っています
一つ目は人々に種類に分断する意味です
茶道教室に通っているかいないかという基準で通っている人のお茶は通っていない人の
お茶とは違うと区別しています
そしてもう一つの意味は
これはお茶じゃないと言っている側の人が他の人をじゃんちする側に立っているという
ことです
これをお茶じゃないという言葉は主に同教室に通っている人が通っていない人に対して
います
教室に通っていることでマジョリティー側に立っているからこそ言える言葉でもあり
ます
つまり
常識や当たり前といった後ろ盾があるからこそ強く言えるというケースは多々あります
逆に言うと
みんなもこうしていると言えるような後ろ盾がない人はマイノリティ側にされがちです
茶道教室を辞めてからは教えてくれる先生も一緒に学ぶ仲間もいなくなりましたが
私は一人でお茶をたてていました
私はあの壁ものと同じぐらいカメラも好きなのでお茶の写真やお茶を使った料理の写真
を毎日取っています
お茶から離れるのではなく
食べて
写真を撮るといった自分の好きな部分だけに絞ったお茶をしたことで新たな価値を
見つけることができました
佐渡ルールで決められている道具も全然使わないため私のするお茶は全然作動らしく
ありません
しかし私はお茶と向き合っている時間はすべてお茶と呼んでいます
大学院でも者人の研究をしていたので私にとっては論文を書く時間をお茶でした
先行していた文化人類学では他人は自分とは違う合理性のもとに生きているということ
を学びました
つまり自分にとっては理解しがたい文化でも誰かにとっては正解かもしれないという
ことです
先ほど例に挙げたう中元やお歳暮現金で払うシステムだって同じことです
持った
先生からしたら食べ物ばかりもらっても食べきれませんし生徒からしても金額の相場が
わかっていないといくら払ったらいいかわからなくて迷ってしまいますよね
[音楽]
だったらお中元とかお歳暮とかいらないんじゃないかと思う方もいるでしょうか
このうちどれかだけが正しいわけではありません
立場が違えば政界も違うのです
文化に優劣はなくある文化を外部の価値観によって測ることができないといった文化
整体主義の考え方やその他の文化人類学者の思想がこれもちゃだと言っている背景には
あると思っています
そして茶人に関する論文を書いたりする一方で人前でお茶をする機会も増えてきました
茶道教室とは程遠いイベントなどでお茶を振る舞ったりする一方でただただひたすら
茶道教室に通う以外にもお茶を楽しむ方法が増えたらいいなと願ってきました
しかしある時に気づいたのですが
人から否定されたくないと思って続けてきた自分の活動が
逆にどれかを否定していることもあります
私は茶人や茶道教室に関する修士論文や文章をネットで公開していますが
私の意図とは異なる反応をいただくこともあります
私が茶道教室で経験したことを話せばそれが事実だろうと反論は必ずあります
しかし私はほかにいくらでももっと素晴らしい教室があることを知っています
佐渡そのものがとても優れた文化であることもわかっています
しかしそれでもと歩け和室で私が経験したこと自体は消えません
その実体験を話すことがこんなにも難しいのだなと
茶道教室以外にもお茶を楽しむ方法はあると
そんな単純な主張することがこんなにも大変なのだなと何度も思ってきました
そのトークだって茶道教室の先生が聞いたら仕事を否定されているように感じるかも
しれません
作動習おうか迷っている人が聞いたら習わない方がいいのかなと思ってしまう可能性も
あります
あくまで私が言いたいのはこれもお茶だというアイディアについてであり教室を否定し
たいわけでも通わないように勧めているわけでもないのにです
茶道を習っている人も私もそれぞれがお茶をしているだけなのにその方法が違えば
食い違ってしまうことはあります
おそらくあなたが何か発言したり行動したりする時も
あなたとは違う考え方で同じことをしようとしている人を刺激しています
良くも悪くもです
私たちが何か発言したり行動したりする時自分と違う考え方の人は必ずいます
そしてその人と自分にとっての正解はそれぞれ異なります
なのにどちらかだけが正解だとしてしまうともう片方は間違いだということになって
しまいます
何か一つだけが絶対的に全員にとって正しく
それ以外はすべて間違いだと言えるほど世界は単純ではありません
だからこそ私が茶道教室に通っていないからといって教室に通わないことがすべての人
に沿っているが正解だなんて思っていません
私のお茶の仕方は世間から浮いていて
同じ温度で同じ熱量でお茶をしている人となかなか出会えない寂しさもあります
つまり私は自分のしていることが誰にとっても正解だとは覚えていないのです
だからこそ自分のしていることこそがお茶だなんて一度も言ったことはありません
これこそがお茶だあれば歌じゃないと断定できるような基準は私たち一人ひとりの心の
中にしかないと思っています
先ほども触れたようにすべての人がそれぞれの合理性に基づいて行動しているので私に
とっての正解は誰かにとっての間違いかもしれません
そんな時にどうしたら誰かを不用意に攻撃することなく自分にとっての正解を貫けるの
でしょうか
それを考えた時にこれもーちゃだというフレーズを使うようになりました
これも何何だということにはどんなメリットがあるでしょうか
[音楽]
すべての人間が違う考え方をして人の数だけ正解があるとき私こそが正解だと言って
しまうだけで自分以外の人がみんな的になってしまいます
しかし考え方の違う人は必ずいるという大前提をもとにこれも何何だということで
自分以外の人を否定せずに済みます
つまり自分にとっての正解を他人に押し付けずに済むのです
その分誰かが嫌な思いをせずに進めます私は長いこと一人でお茶をたててきましたが
これもちゃだと言い続ける過程で明らかにお茶じゃない人たち
つまり異分野の人たちとコラボすることも増えてきました
ん
3 d プリンタや現代音楽が専門の方々
エンジニアの方々などですか分野の人がその分野とお茶の交わりそうな部分を見つけ
これもお茶じゃないかと言ってくれたことで新たな価値を創り出すことができ
私は自分の実力以上のことを成し遂げられてきました
だからこれもーちゃだと居続けることにはただお茶をしているだけではありえない化学
反応を起こす力があります
これこそがお茶だと言い切れる強さとはまた違う力があります
[音楽]
他分野の人がこれもちゃだと言ってくれることは私にとって最高の後ろ盾に感じました
これもーちゃだという簡単な言葉ですが私の考え方を理解してもらえているように感じ
られたのです
[音楽]
そのため他人を否定したいことは回り回って味方を増やすことにもなると思っています
人の数だけ正解があるこの世界で敵を作らないことは難しいかもしれません
しかし誰かを否定しないように自分の意見を主張することが出来ればむやみに敵を
増やすことなく自分の主張と共鳴してくれる人とつながれます
[音楽]
あなたがもし自分こそが正しいと言いたくなった時はこれもお茶だという謎のクルーズ
を少しだけ覚えだしていただきたいです
[音楽]
これこそが何何だという否定ではなくこれも
なになりだという考え方で他の人の中にも自分の中にも価値を見つけることができると
思っています
ありがとうございました